allez les chéris ce weekend a eu lieu au
Salvador l'élection de Miss Univers la
France était représenté par dianler Miss
France 2022 elle est avec nous ce soir
elle vient d'arriver du Salvador
apparemment là voilà laatri là y a
quelques instants pour nous dévoiler
toutes les colis de sa prestation et
apparemment elle a été harcelée sur les
réseaux ouais c'est ce que les équipes
m'ont dit allez avec nous dans un
instant regardez ça bah ça regardez sa
prestation et d'ailleurs Jacques cardose
je pense que tu vas prendre dans laole
parance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça
va
alors est avec nous vous connaissez bien
Guillaume Genton vous avez travaillé
avec lui tous les matins ouis je suis
hyper contente on s'était pas revu
depuis la fin de la radio c'est vrai
ouais non fécitations merciah pourquoi
bah pour
l'enfant C je crois que tuta tes parins
quand même non ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que je suis
le Parin par contre vous vous voyez he
on est pas chezmo pardon non mais non
mais je rigole ça va bon alors comment
s'est passé le concours Miss Univers bah
ça s'est bien passé j'étais hyper fierè
franchement c'était un grand moment moi
monter sur la scène de Miss Univers
quand même on part de très loin bac Mo
10 en défilé ça s'est vu d'ailleurs
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce
que vous avez dit que vous avez eu un
petit problème à l'œil ouais en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que on m'a
maquillé du coup par les équipes sur
place euh là-bas et en fait je suis
allergique à l' micellaire non et donc
ils ont voulu me démaquiller pour
refaire mon maquillage et donc ça allit
dans mon œil alors je voulais revenir
sur ça entendu dire hier tuas ét victime
d'avant hier non mais j'ai avantors vous
venez d'arriver en plus hein là vous
venez d'arriver ouis je arrivé à 13h
donc je suis encore qu mais du coup j'ai
quand même regardé était dit sur
l'émission et je voulais vous remercier
parce que c'est vrai j'ai entendu du
coup que apparemment avoir un handicap à
l'œil n'empêchz pas de marcher du coup
je vous mets au défi mettez des talons
de cm Un maillot de bain un œil en moins
et je vous regarde sur
[Musique]
scène
ule cel il était tranquillen dernière la
gueule j'ai une à lui dire mais
excuse-moi je vois pas où est le
problème relève le défi
vasyule vas avec les les machins au pied
là
non
uneè vous avz portiez un costume à 25000
boules ou après c'est pas moi qui l'
payé c'est Bou rouge pour confectionner
effectivement un costume qui vaut 25000
€ il est hyper beau magnifique ouais
ouais très fier on j' un peu le F à
l'air mais céit très joli et c'est c'est
c'est vous êtes à l'aise là qu'on vous
défiler comme ça de pas du tout mais al
moi la scène c'est pas mon truc he
clairement donc c'est pour ça aussi que
je me suis fait taper sur les doigts
j'étais pas du tout à l'aise c'est c'est
c'est hyper dur bah là j'ai essayé de le
cacher au maximum c'est une grosse
préparation ou pas ouais ouais moi ça
até une grosse c'est quoi genre on
prépare comment pour être déjà moi j'ai
perdu quasiment 10 kg
hein mais parce qu'il fallait que mon
mental ne marchait plus avec mon corps
c'est-à-dire que j'ai un mental hyper de
sportive et mon corps s'était laissé
aller la radio et cetera ça faisait que
j'avais pris un petit peu de dit tout
suite c'est la faute de Guillaume Gon
mais voilà voilà on a pris on a pris
ensemble on était uni il était pas perdu
encore voilà ils on pris 25 he de cours
de CATW mais ça s'est pas trop vu de
défilé et puis après toute une toute la
communication et cetera qui avait autour
pour réussir à faire une belle comme à
l' internationale ouais mais par que
vous étiez dans les favoris avant le
concours ouais carrément ouais c'était
ça c'est ma plus grosse fierté c'est
qu'on a été dans les favoris jusqu'à la
dernière seconde quasiment jusqu moment
mon sur scène en fait vous vous trouvez
que vous avez raté votre ouais ouais
c'était loupé c'était loupé la CE vous
ont raté je trouve c'est que vous êtes
plus belle au naturel que là
j'aiimpression il vous ont
raté c'est pas faux non c'est vrai en
fait c'était un peu ce qu' pas fa ça va
vous le
mon ça vaouard c'est pas fau non mais
pas dans le sens où je suis beaucoup
plus jolie en vra mais dans le sens où
il m' un pe peu saboté c'est vrai je
pense que l'équipe maquillage qui était
latine voulait pas forcément une franise
elle est pas victime de
l'antifrance il a un peu en tout cas je
sais pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
je me suis retrouvé avec une mèche
brûlée le maquillage complètement loupé
j'ai une photo de mon maquillage c'est
une atrocité j'ai dû tout reprendre 20
minutes avant le plateau parce que ma
nan est venue me voir en disant
clairement ils t'ont saboté faut que tu
fasses tout quoi et quand nan elle te le
dit sur place les
nanuniv qu' a eu sabotage j'aimerais
croire que non mais en tout cas bon
voilà après ça déstabilise c'est sûr
après ça n'empêche rien que j'étais
mauvaise sur scène et ça c'est pas
réclam oui bonsoir Dian c'était en
Amérique centrale d'accord c'est une
nicaraguayenne qui gagne on a vu dans
les finalistes il y a beaucoup de
sud-américaines il fa voilà 7/ 10 voilà
il faut le dire c'est truqué vous avez
été vous avez été victime d'un trucage
TR non non alors franchement ma ma
prestation sur Cène était mauvaise il
faut se le dire en fait les latines non
mais les latines elles sont dans le
ventre de leur mère elles étaient déjà
en train de boucher les hanches que moi
j'étais coincé quoi donc il y a un
moment aussi ça aide he clairement elle
l' dans la peau et la scène à Miss
Univers c'est pas comme Miss France la
scène est primordiale c'estàd que pour
pour eux ce qui se passe le soir même
ils s'en fichent des deux semaines avant
de prépare rien à voir avec Miss France
le moi est pris en considération là eux
c'est sur scène et rien d'autre donc si
le soir même tu es pas au top de ta
forme c'est pas pour toi et moi c'était
pas ma bonne étoile c'était pas mon
moment tu vois tu connaissais pas le Do
vou pas le dire on voulait pas le dire
que c'est trucqué le maquillage tout
çare sourire que c'est trucé diis désolé
on va avoir le sacre de Miss Nicaragua
vous allez n dire ce que vous en pensez
vous avez fait vous êtes fait des
copines là-bas grave contrairement Miss
France av été plus dur tu vois quel euh
moi c'était toute l'équipe Europe ah
ouais Allemagne et et Royaume-Uni
vraiment c'était Nicaragua non non
j'avoue je pas par pas très bien anglais
je pas trop trop par voir parce que
c'est c'est Miss fr elle elle a combien
de
dents c'est pas
vra aussi vousz mais c'est comme ça en
fait faut avoir beaucoup de dents qui Fa
avoir faut aimer les chic
ouy c'est
[Musique]
parti ch
avoir
alors on va
revoir on va revoir la thaïlandaise moi
je préférais la thaïlandaise très belle
la thaïlandaise grandes favoritees ah
elle aussi elle a 82 sa qui elle aurait
gagné c'était pareil on aurait dit que
c'est truqué parce que la nouvelle ce de
Miss Univers est thaïlandaise donc on
aurait dit c'é sûrement à cause de ça
justement toujour la chirurgie
esthétique tout sont toutes la chirurgie
esthétique on fait partie des seuls pays
quasiment qui n'en ont pas vous pensez
quoi vous des polémiques autour des
femmes transj qui ont peut participer et
cetera j'ai trouvais ça génial
honnêtement et en fait ce qui était beau
dans le top 20 c'est que justement
c'était hyper inclusif alors ça a été
tapédessus parce que justement ça amène
à la légitimité de se dire est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il fallait l'inclusivité
ou non qu' arrivent là moi en tout cas
personnellement ce que j'ai aimé dans le
concours c'est queon ne pouvait pas
savoir qui était trangeur ou non c'est
que vraiment il y avait une acceptation
de tout le monde qu'on a peut-être pas
encore assz en France mais vraiment
c'était mais elles était avec nous
toutes on était toutes des femmes fièes
quoi et ça c'était beau à voir c'est
quoi l'histoire de harcèlement bah en
fait suite au préliminar du coupt qui la
préssélection où je suis pour la
première fois monté sur scène étant
donné que j'étais grande favorite tout
le monde m'est tombé dessus en disant
qu'en gros je savais pas défiler et que
j'avais un peu déçu tous les Français et
en fait j'ai surtout pris une vague de
haine de gens qui m'en veulent encore de
Miss France pourquoi parce que quand
j'ai été Miss France vous le savez
j'étais venu ici j'étais pas la première
du public ah ouais et et donc il y avait
une première du public et on a voulu
pendant très longtemps d'avoir pris la
place de la première du public malgré
qu'elle était 5e du jury et moi première
du public don du jury donc forcément
j'avais pris sa place et là j'ai repris
ce ce V en disant que je me méritais pas
depuis le début d'être miss France
encore moins d'être là je pense que j'ai
reçu quasiment 2000 messages j'ai j'ai
j'ai un truc dire moi sur Miss France
alors j'adore la Miss France cette année
mais écoutez j'ai l'impression que Miss
France en fait tout le monde s'en fout
maintenant excusez-moi de vous dire ça
hein euh j'ai on s'en fout on sait même
pas qui sont les les dernières Miss
France à part vous êtes la dernière
c'est Mo dernière Mo vous êtes la
dernière dont on se souvient mais celle
d'avant sou
C celle d'avant' souvient pas celle
d'avant non
plus un pe
Amandine qui peut me donner le prénom de
la Miss France non mais parce que toi tu
es un
vicieux per toi es un pervers un mec
normal qui pouvait donner le
prénom on pas fois moi j'ai de la chance
de faire grâce à vous de faire de la
radio ex qui m'a permis auss d'avoir un
plus de de lumière et après au-delà de
ça on n'oublie pas que Indira a 19 Ansou
et aussi que l'année de Miss France on
nous reproche beaucoup on n dit on vous
voit plus pendant l'année n'oublions pas
quand même que le but de Miss France
c'est d'aller en région c'est souvent
après qu'on découvre des Miss France
deième chose mais d'accord alors c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est la prod c'est quoi
non mais je on a le départ de Syvie
Tellier ouais il y avait quand même la
résonance de l'image de Syvie qu'on a
plus aujourd'hui on précise quand
mêmeourui Cindy mais c'est pas m de pad
tout ou Cindy excusez-moi n'a pas la
même résonance que Sylvie faire une
raquette de padle oui mais très bien
mais déjà
beaucoup je suis désolé oui et en
parlant de CIV est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec avec elle qui a parlé de
Miss Népal qui a dit qu'elle était pas
très gracieuse cette miss un peu avec
des formes est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elle ou est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est déplacé oh alors j'ai pas entendu
exactement ce qu'elle a dit c'est
peut-être en était pas pour la
discrimination positive et que et que du
coup elle l'a trouvait pas Gracieuse ce
qui est alors moi moi personnellement
j'étais contente qu'elle soit dedans
parce que de toute manière ça prouve que
justement ils sont inclusiv il fallait
faire top 20 ouais ou super est-ce que
c'est mérité est-ce que tu trouves que
c'est mérité je je trouve que c'est
mérité alors après si on avait jugé de
semaines sur place de comportement
peut-être qu'elle aura pas été dedans
est-ce qu'elle est plus belle que
toelle pas le meilleur comportement je
pense pour êre dans lesainso c'est des
comportements c'est la politesse c'est
les hires et traité non non non pas du
tout a des propos et les Prenn en
considération à Miss France ça sera
jamais passé elle faisait quoi mais j'en
sais rien
touoi camarade elle était pas bonne
camarade
peutreil mais bien mais AC d'autres elle
a eu des comportements parfis qui éta un
peu déplacé c'est fou ça donc ça aura pu
elle aurait pu voilà pour ça mais par
contre pour le message qu'elle envoyait
effectivement c'est peut-être plus
impactant qu'une nana qui vient juste en
étant ê mérite d'arriver devant toi un
concours de beauté honnêtement mais
honnêtementes
les
trséseres les
femours le but c'est pas de représenter
toutes les FEM la femme la plus jolie
c'est
pour pas une forme de taille aussi
ce concrezous sur les tout à
l'heure quoi mais mais faut arrêterours
di est beaucoup plus
belle un sondage qui trouve Miss Npal
plus belle que Dian au Népal elle a été
él
excusem au Népal elleé je suis désolé
c'est pas on confond les concours Miss
France par exemple avec les concours
élite manquin je suis désolé c'est pas
un concours
voilà donc c'est bien qu'il ait des
différences tuevens de croisière
toi mais
SCZ vu hier les 30 cme-oi calmei on
parler toi dans un instant et calme-toi
l LEED non mais alors ça va être quoi la
suite là maintenant ah oui alors déjà là
ça va être de se reposer un petit peu si
je suis honnête parce que je je quand
même pas arrêté depuis la fin de M
France en fait moi j'ai pas eu d'arrêt
je pensais qu'après m allit redescendre
ça allait pas été avec la radio et
ensuite Miss Univers et par la suite
déjà là je vais être au J sletion C anné
la Miss France ah oua donc je je
choisirai nos 15 ah ou et pour la suite
je pense qu'il y aura des il y a des
projets il y a des choses que je
réfléchis avec les miss je pense qu'il y
a un truc à faire autour de ça ouais il
y a peut-être quelque chose à faire
voilà il y a un bail qui avec qui avec
la société non en tout cas dans ma tête
il y a un truc et qui va être vais voir
on va voir on votre tête ou c'est déjà
avancé discuté ça été discuté ça se
discute dis discuté avec la société qui
produit ou pas pas encore il faut en
discuter justement
je fa discuter non mais je sais pas je
on verra non
mais l'idée bien ou bien l'idée bien
vous le senteid chouette ouais mais
après je sa peutêre a de chosere de la
radio à nouveau peut-être de la T vous
me direz vous avez mon
numéro ça se fait a son numéro vous
parce que cétait
mon
bffaire rien Jean-Michel c'est in mais
qu'est-ce qui non mais travaille un peu
travaille un peu au t'occuper de tes
meufs